to that we normally just try to ignore
the show's antics but today joyless
behar
said something so outrageous well we'll
share it with you she said
antifa is just a quote fictitious idea
a thing that doesn't even exist really
joy
antifa isn't real then what's on the
screen
right now over there is that not real do
you
really think antipa had nothing to do
with the hundred straight days of riots
in portland last summer
all right joining us now with a special
investigation into whether antifa
is real fox news contributor former
secret service agent dan bongino
all right dan is it fictitious or is it
real
well sean you know fictitious entities
don't put people in body bags
um and that's what happened in oregon
when a patriot prayer
member was killed by a member of antifa
the convenient you know joy behar
doesn't know that joy behar is
frankly kind of dumb so she probably
doesn't read the newspaper but she may
want to read that obituary obituary
of that man who was killed by the
fictitious entity who killed him
a known antifa supporter also sean one
other thing
um from personal experience having
walked out of the white house tonight
trump accepted the gop
nod into a crowd of antifa and blm
one of whom threatened to rape my wife
while i watched
yes that actually happened by the way um
i assure you that was not
uh a fiction novel that actually
happened my wife was there multiple
people saw it
um and i actually got it on tape and i
promise you those weren't actors those
weren't role players
those were actual antifa people
following me and my wife back to this
hotel
threatening all kinds of nasty things um
so no it is not a fictitious
fictitious entity um joy behar's triple
digit iq
is an act of fiction um not antifa
yeah well i i think it's pretty obvious
i don't know why it's so hard for some
people
okay radicalism is radicalism right
uh if you have organizers in
black lives matter chanting what do we
want dead cops what
when we want them now and pigs in a
blanket okay
very different separate we distinguish
between those that were protesting
many peacefully after the george floyd
incident
uh when you can't just why can't we just
acknowledge
people that are right why is that so
hard for people
like what happened on january 6 we can't
have our capital
rated like that no it's not you just did
it it's not hard for you and me
and there's a reason i've said it on
this show multiple times
conservatives sean have an emergency
break on their behavior that emergency
break
is is faith family and big r god-given
rights we believe liberals have those
too i know this is a shocker to liberals
but we don't want to take your freedom
of speech
we certainly don't want to attack you
for it and we don't want to prevent you
from assembling or petitioning the
government
government because we believe you have
big our god-given rights listen to me
and listen
clear liberals have no such emergency
break not all democrats
radical leftists are obsessed with power
and violence
and have no emergency break on their
behavior at all they don't give a damn
about god-given rights at all and that's
why this is
difficult for you and me facilitates it
by denying what is basic reality
let's stick with joyless bayhard listen
to what she had to say about the cuomo
issue
what worries me is that if he resigns
and
you know fast forward down the line a
republican becomes the governor
of new york state a lot of things will
happen that i won't be happy with i
don't want some republican coming in
there and overturning some of these
policies
and then exonerating or pardoning trump
who was going to be indicted in new york
state
so let me get this straight seven women
can come forward the i believe a caucus
is
quiet let's keep cuomo in office because
we
hate donald trump that much we have less
than a minute i mean did you listen to
the
i i know you get to see these cuts
before did you just listen to what you
just said
is that even sane i mean seriously is
that even
of this earth is this woman even of
planet earth like is she thinking
do you realize what she just said is
that a real or rhetorical question
i know i know it's just sean it's
painful to watch
every single night these people have no
principles these are the same democrats
who tell you they want to hike your
taxes
when they park their boats in rhode
island rather than massachusetts to
avoid paying the tax bill like john
kerry
they're the same people who swear
government health care is a panacea
and then argue to get obamacare not
applied to them while they're in
congress
they're nothing but frauds dan bongino
great to have you as always
more hannity right